[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody we are here in the
first match of the american cup 2022 and
we already have a few people that are
going on on the championship bracket but
we have an incredible amount of five
playoffs for all of you it is a set of
two game mini matches of ten plus five
here we see the format on screen and
exciting games two rapid game matches
playoff games ten plus five as i was
mentioning if still tied after that we
got the armageddon games five minutes
for white formulas for black black wins
if the game ends in a draw there is a
two second increment starting from move
60 but before that we expect all of the
pieces to fly off the board
and this is gonna be just extremely
exciting let's take a look at the
brackets oh sorry the games that we are
about to witness yeah this is this is
great this is absolutely great we had
five decisive games in the first
classical uh game of day one but we also
have five matches five playoff matches
and uh we have jeffrey zhang versus fabi
karjawana pick him
i'm gonna go with fabi there i think
he's a more experienced player in rapid
and the second match shanklin against
dominguez uh the
lower seed is getting white to start
these a mini match sam shanklin
considers himself an underdog against
lanier i think that he is but
less than what he
predicted for himself he uh mentioned a
sixty percent chance for dominguez
that's very high it's huge yeah it's
huge i think the shang clan is a very
slight underdog if anything in this in
this especially with the amount of work
that he has been putting into his rapid
play in the last couple of years
specifically rapid play right and then i
think that he's become a much stronger
player in this format and i i still
think the minis is a slight has a slight
edge but it's really not very much and
in our marquee match up our number one
levon aronian i mean my goodness he won
and rey bounced back in a must-win game
that we just saw
and this playoff
this is a spicy one it's not just
because spicy caterpillar is in it but
it's also a good one aronian suffering a
lot and normally you have some time to
rest sometimes to recover but no boom
right into the playoffs boom and no no
rest for the worry and robson just comes
hot off a win certainly the win behind
his sails let's see if he can convert it
into
a win in the playoffs and how big a win
was that for ray robson because it cost
lavonne
some classical rating points which was
very very close to fabi and we do have
an olympia team coming up but then in
the ladies yeah i have the feeling that
the old i think they're both in the
olympia i think they're both in the
olympic but i was just wondering which
which place uh who's number one that's
true i will have to check in meanwhile
alice lee certainly with chances both
yesterday and today we do have we do
think that she had winning positions in
both though to be fair she did have a
losing position as well yeah exactly
we'll be playing against international
masters davila tolakiru this one is
going to be quite interesting i have not
seen alice lee play rapid ever and i do
coach uh star rule and i know that rapid
is one of her fortes so i would like to
see this match i'm gonna have to give my
student the edge here just because of
the experience on ten plus five speaking
of experience in the other ladies
match-up talk about uh two players who
know the measure of one another they've
been playing against each other in u.s
women's championships for the better
part of the decade maybe two yeah
she's amazing i was actually surprised
that that have mentioned that she has a
bad record in tie bricks because one of
the
tiebreaks that i do remember her winning
was against anna satonski i want to say
this was the
2017 or 18 us women's championship there
was a three-way tie at the end irina
anna and tatif
and irina had the better tiebreak went
on to wait
for the winner of anna and tatef and it
was tata that uh beat anna and to ended
up losing to irena and getting second
place there we see a very lonely man
gathering his thoughts and jeffrey
gathering his thoughts in a different
way
as a jeffrey zhang playing the white
pieces against thabby that match
coming up very very shortly voiced for a
battle here jumping christian
do you see anybody as being very clear
favorites i mean i still have to go with
leveronian as being one of the big
favorites going into these playoffs but
once again we're going back to the
intangibles
the momentum is behind ray robson and we
know that he actually has a lot of
experience in this type of mini matches
i remember he played a very important
match against wesley saw and some other
players in one millionaire chess
2014 he went all the way to the finals
he lost that finals against uh wesley
saw but he does have a lot of experience
in this type of uh mini match rapid
situation so i do have my eyes on that
one i still have leveronian as a big
favorite uh let's see how he handles
that painful loss
yeah it's very tough but normally
speaking the painful he seems to be
quite happy
you've got a you you've got a night to
uh
heal yourself uh here he'll have to go
right back in but as you were saying he
looks pretty
relaxed
i think that's the advantage of the
experience right this is no way the
first time that levon loses his damage
before yeah he comes back knows what is
at stake knows how to do it also that's
the advantage of having an extra life i
can guarantee you if this was an
elimination from the tournament
situation the tension would have been
much higher yeah good point good point
indeed and this one this traditional
matchup of the us women's championship
tactic against anna
wow that was a roller coaster of a game
it did feel that anna was just close to
bringing it back really was she had a
terrible position out of the opening
that petrov really boomeranged against
her she was losing losing losing
fighting fighting fighting probably
close to a draw at the very end when
she's blundered and i feel this is also
very interesting because both of the
repertoires are relatively narrow and it
feels that tatev lost yesterday but not
out of the opening whereas anna feels
that she got a terrible position from
the opening and then she has 40 minutes
to prepare something new right that's
tough yes and that is a very good point
alejandro because these players are
basically repeating 40 minutes after
they finish their games they're
repeating the same colors
so is ray robson going to play something
for her
i don't think we're going to be allowed
we're not going to see a fight
[Laughter]
good point good point uh in one match
that the players really have not really
landed any blows against one another is
the fabi jeffrey match as well as the
sam shanklin versus lanier match i don't
think either of those
players have really uh
yeah they weren't able to really open up
the position against each other very
close matches there as we see yes and
there we go sam shanklin against lanier
dominguez c4 okay c5
let's go three he plays fast wow
storming through the gates right now d4
not what i expected from shank when he's
usually such a deep theoretical
thinker exactly this is already taking
linear out of his uh his comfort zone
his normal
routine
so in this position e7 e6 as well as a
b7 b6 and even g7 g6 now g6 is not
really a linear's uh no he's not going
there so i suspect e6 but he did play
the grunfeld for a long time so he might
be attempting that yeah yeah the problem
with g6 is that it allows d5
he might not want to go into those which
is a kind of a benoni where you've
committed yourself to e3 so here you can
go d5 and we've transposed in that case
directly to a karo khan guess what g6
well we're probably going to see d5 very
soon
yeah you can start with d5 or you can go
g6 first and then
a game where where
viktor korchnoy who is notorious not
only for grabbing pawns but for grabbing
space played a move like d4 d5 here as
white yes just
to stop
from getting in deep one of the craziest
games i've seen uh live was uh vladimir
putin against yarala yaroslav jerrybrook
who really likes to play the group field
the game went d4 knight f6 c4 g6 d5
i don't know what it is but it's not a
group holiday here once again
uh
knight f3 uh we could see uh uh
uh kara khan part of
look at this he didn't want to see black
playing d5 but
can this loss of the tempo really bring
oh white success no i feel like e6
the e file comes and if you get to play
rookie one check rookie a check part me
and knight e4
i feel that black has gone past linear
he's playing fast though so he must know
what he's doing now we see this uh
symmetrical structure on the d file but
knight a6 knight c5 generally comes very
quickly or knight a6 knight c7 putting a
lot of pressure on that pawn on d5 you
like knight a6 knight c7 i'm always
thinking knight a6 to c5 c5 also to to
jump to the e4 square
but it's not a benoni what do we call
this
i don't think it has a name
it doesn't even have a name no
all right and what about the rest of the
games well let's take a look at what
aronian is doing guys maybe we can jump
maybe christian you're going to take
that one sure yep uh i will because we
do have not a reiteration of what we've
seen but definitely
something similar i don't have moves on
mine let me see if you can
question you can take it away yes i can
indeed
we can do that or we can have the bird's
eye view but i can definitely take this
one away just to please see how we got
to where we are yeah we can't really see
the board from this angle we might
by the way it is it is a
english
as they played earlier today
and in that position
where
uh
there was no
no bishop f5 bishop f5 bishop f5 was the
move that lavon did instead of bishop f8
that's right bishop f5 bishop f5 d3
queen d7 knight e4 f6 and we've caught
up with the players he played f6 yeah
no knight fights no knight he's not
getting any 95's that's it
it's over no muss
and
okay uh
as white you're kind of happy because
you are looking at this knight c5 you do
get to win the two bishops whether
that's a massive advantage or not
probably not especially when i'm i'm
seeing that bishop h3
is on black's agenda which he's done
right away to deny this bishop on g2
yeah this makes a lot of sense the
traditional way of fighting against this
dragon bishop is changing it off
immediately lots to be said for trading
it off and let me just go around the
horn very quickly again this is the
linear game he did put his knight on c5
whoa
fast
uh
let's just see how fabi and
oh this is a
jeffrey
yeah a trump
c5
and look at them go they blitz their way
right to this position
although jeffrey still hasn't spent any
time this is the first time he's
thinking he's over 10 minutes
and five is the one that's spending time
getting to this position remember it's a
playoff of game 10 plus five as it says
on the screen exactly so that extra five
seconds you mean jeffrey has used it
to
maintain history all of his time all of
his time
okay we'll keep an eye on that and in
our ladies matchup
we have ana
this is
very similar to what we saw but she did
play c4
early
yeah
which she did not earlier uh today i'm
not sure about bishop takes c5 i thought
bishop d4 was the move but okay a long
game certainly there quickly to look at
alice lee this looks like one of those
classical queens gamble decline f3
where white is slowly slowly slowly but
certainly playing for the central
break e3 e4 but again uh for me guys uh
lavonne and anytime you see a game
that's really caught your attention let
me know because uh yeah we'll keep an
eye on it but let's keep up with this
ray robson against the wonder onion game
i think the favi game will also be spicy
but
what what is going on here queen e6 it
feels that lavon is taking a completely
different approach to the same variation
of the english in which he's just not
allowing white any type of play he
doesn't allow d4 he doesn't allow rook
takes c6 he's just controlling us i say
that d4 on the board exactly i wanted to
say why does it stop why did the move
queen e6 stop the move d4 uh when the
queen was on the d7 square the move d4
becomes much more attractive because of
the opportunity of gaining a tempo
against the queen
nitrates on d4 i'm anticipating rook
takes d4
yeah and then i would imagine that black
will play c6 in order to secure himself
the perch
on the d5 square no lavon said my c7
pawn is not hanging because
queen takes c7 tactics and the knight on
e4
will be the one hanging at the end of
the day rook d eight
okay i would probably
i know
or something okay guys lebron is still
in his theory yeah
sorry levon is still in his theory right
now he's just banging all of them yeah
he hasn't even spent his time he's
following a game right now he's studied
this he's following a game and he caught
his opponent because ray only has five
minutes that's double the time levon has
doubled the time of raid that's a huge
advantage and after rook to d8 it seems
like also the computer is agreeing that
the position is going to probably
simplify and it seems like white has not
gotten anything out of this opening wow
and in fact which game are the players
following it seems to be a
correspondence game
sikorsky versus mandy some 2500s i've
never heard of so it must be
correspondence exactly as i was about to
say that bobby fisher in particular in
interviews said that he followed
correspondence games
uh carefully because he felt that was
like an incredible
pure form of chess and the fact that you
could spend years on a single game he
took the correspondence guys very
seriously
and we still do every i think every
modern top grand master
looks at correspondence games to get
ideas for the openings exactly if you
play c5 then he knows it
he knows everything
c5 huh c5 is the move played in that uh
stem game your and if c5 well knight
takes e5 queen cease so actually in that
game rook
rook to d1 so rook to d1 was the first
novelty rook takes d4 rook takes d4 but
now the engine is recommending c5
the engine is recommended and i'm pretty
sure he played it c5 on the board
he knows it yeah he knows what he's
doing right now and the whole point of
course is the pawn is not hanging knight
takes c6 would be egregiously
a mistake after queen c6 double
attack check on
the king
as well as the knight on c5 so we
anticipate the rook dropping back
or something first like
this position always feels much nicer to
play for black because of the absence of
the light square bishops yeah it's it's
easier when
when black doesn't have uh that the
other point though is i always like
these lines of play from the opening
from black's point of view because
there's no targets yes yeah i mean if
yeah if you can get your knight to c5
and you can do something nice over there
maybe you you get something but there's
no big splash splash on the king side
the center has been eviscerated so no
targets no targets no i like black's
position you guys going to move rook d
to c4 is extremely logical uh c4 already
on the board yep and it's that time
advantage that levon has built up yeah
that scares me a little bit for ray ray
already down to three minutes and 45
seconds that's not a lot of time fastest
seven minutes in chats right
i mean the physics where rey is
concerned uh the space time continuum
as this man uh spends too much time uh
and levon is just ruthless he's just
missing everything every move blitzed
out
and which should be four and it almost
feels like black's getting the
initiative no no isn't it at this point
with the white pieces you want to pull
the brakes right yeah as fast as
possible
you're trying to simplify the position
as fast how do i exchange every single
position every single piece on on the
board right that's the question that you
have to answer well this last move
bishop b4 in particular put the put the
onus on white because
in my view
black wants to take this pawn on b3 and
continue with rook c8
the pin
knight
uh to the rook as well as pinning the
knight to the queen so guys what's the
first move that comes into your mind
it's not a tricky question what's for
for white right now for white i would
say what would you play rook d4 okay
rook d4 alejandro
uh
e3 would you ever consider taking on c4
no no that's the best move in the
position what
but it's not you you cannot play you
cannot take on c4 and allow the knight
to jump in into the game like that right
that's where i stop
yeah right i mean yeah knight attacks
the rook the knight attacks the bishop
it doesn't look good right yeah it's a
bad look king g1 i do understand he
wants to get a away from any ideas of a
queen c6 check big trouble already but
now once again i thought the threat or
he did play rook c8 i thought the threat
was to take on b3 and play rook c8
but maybe this is actually even
the best move right you know the better
move order
the time difference no no i still think
he knows what he's doing i still think
he analyzes things
he's playing everything
he's playing the best moves
objectively in the position as he's
about to say the move queen d1 does not
solve two minutes and 14 seconds and
counting for ray that's incredible queen
d1 you take on b3 rook check king f7
there's uh the knight on c3 is hanging
that would cost white material again uh
ray down on the clock but also the
position this is the pressure under
pressure practically this is over
exactly uh yeah it's harder
this pinned
knight
that taking on c4 was the best move
it's incredible you don't even look at
it wow that's the thing that's the thing
you you're not even going to consider it
in the first 10 moves right right you're
going to think about rook d4 e3 solidify
the position king g1 maybe the move that
he played never take on c4 right but
it's the best move and the only move
that equalizes by the way at this exact
moment i don't have a good suggestion
for white yeah
i mean you also have one minute and
counting and you have to make uh a move
and i have to make so many threats
already exactly that pin knight on c3 is
really wow an issue nine minutes and 37
seconds
an insane time advantage insane
first of two games remember that robson
will have another chance if if he loses
this one but he would have to win with
black against lavon ronin yeah winning
on demand with white is tough enough
i mean you don't want to you don't want
to give yourself that challenge you
don't want the black in this one no no
no no but 43 seconds rt4 finally played
i was about to say i didn't have another
suggestion but even this i know
uh i'm in trouble but if you take if you
take on b3 yes
and then you can take on c3 and then you
take on c3 and knight d5 what's
happening there no ninety-five year old
c4 that was the move i thought yeah
c4 you have to play queen c6 queen
c6 we have it on the analysis board you
attack the bishop you force
these three and then attack that bishop
with knight d5 and that's all she's
right she wrote yeah and that's a winner
that's easy to see that's it so that
might be the first
uh result of the playoffs exactly such
an easy win for him he made it
effortless he really did and uh ray
uh just well what can i say never got
out of the opening here let's just take
a quick again
hold on because cb3 was played and rey
is down to 30 for 40 seconds
thinking about a takes b3 that's a bad
sign the guy takes your pawn on b3
you're thinking about it
what's the alternative moving your queen
queen takes b3 just loses a piece yeah
so you got to play a b a b 3.
queen e4 excuse me i'll show you
what i mean this is pretty lost yeah
queen e4 just take back you have to take
with the rook take then rook c2 or
something along those lines oh it's a
little tricky yeah because rook c2 i'll
take on b4 queen e4 it's remarkable that
no you just take it right so
how does you got to take with the knife
yeah and then i take it and then rook
takes before and i go check
and then i'm not queening the pawn
that's my whole point
i'm
that's a nice one that is that is cute
those are kind of forced i don't see
another move that's not cool that's
beautiful that is a beautiful sequence
right there
yeah well let's take let's stick with
this one because i think we're going to
see an end shake right actually very
soon very
yes exactly because no one is double
checking his variations
and he played it so fast this whole game
blitz through this game wow wow
there's a reason why this guy's the
number one seed coming into this event
right i mean he's just making it look
easy as you were saying but
trust me it's not you handle a player
like ray robson's caliber in this style
you're not easy just you know applaud no
no no no no this is and to come back
after losing uh classical that's not
easy this is a masterpiece
and we're being told that jeffrey and
fabi are headed to a drop not really
sure why
but
okay
queen takes c4 is on the board knight
takes c4 let's see if he takes on a2 now
this is the critical moment
it's a nice variation to leave the
bishop on b4 hanging yes it's also not
too difficult no it's not for a level no
but he has to make it
and kudos to ray for finding queen e4
because atex b3 was just losing his
bodies
we saw the knight d5 line and it wasn't
it wasn't too much to talk about give
yourself as many chances as possible
that's the best you can do
we're being told that young alice lee is
winning her i have no idea why they're
saying that but
okay and alice lee is in a fight against
arula i don't know why that's a huge
fight i mean it's just a fight yeah it
looks like a good battle going on here
wouldn't say it's uh winning or anything
but uh good fight okay come on come on
we have other games to see yeah i know i
want to move over i mean take on a2 uh
rook c1 or rook c2 by the way uh
rooksy one was a little fancy on my my
part but rook c2 would also i'm sure no
but rook city
yes no but rook city you allow bishop
d4 right
bishop d4
okay i'm not i'm not saying he's getting
anywhere right you probably just take
only two you take on e2 and you keep
collecting right but but that was why i
wanted to play right to be one so that
you didn't even have bishop to do
exactly we all agree with you exactly
yeah yeah okay no you're uh
that was conventionally oh you you want
something sick yes you want to check
okay anyway right now right rooks you
want right now and then and then rugby
on the rook strapped
no
broken people oh
we're putting that on the analysis board
that is safe
okay
see if he's going to put it on the board
as well no no
but that would have been nice that would
have been very good
you don't see a rook track trapped on b4
that is beautiful yeah
but i have a feeling that
everything is getting a little bit uh
yeah
wow okay he did play f5 after rook c2
bishop d4 f5 99 g5 then he attacked the
bishop yet again with the move rook d2
i guess you have to go to e5
maybe you can go to
c3 yeah now drop back to c3 yeah watch
out knight d5 rook takes b7
is still elizabeth there's the back rack
made threats you gotta be a little
careful there okay young alice lee from
uh well the producers told us she's
winning now she's completely losing
producer's curse exactly producers first
there's a commentator's curse for the
producer's card
yeah
well being told is the var curse
time time how much
clock time did he use two seconds five
second bonus yes uh knight jumps to e6
and i must say lavon is an oh oh
i apologize knight to b5
that's a crush yeah but this this bond
is promoting that there's no stopping
the pawn now knight takes c3 on the
board and that will be a full rook and
wrestling nation
king h8 well not full rock i guess you
got enough pawns but
not the six not six you got two
yes i i think we can move from this game
i do too
let's jump to that alice lee game that
seems to have
captured the attention of our producer
what is going on here b3 takes a4 let me
count the pieces exactly okay let me
tell you material's actually even what
material is exactly even two three yeah
but look at the activity of black
species yeah but black hold on e4 is
hanging
so if we can get well well it's not
really happening
that's a light squared bishop i
apologize absolutely so i could take on
a4 i could just play bishop c6 and
threaten e3
i like that that that looks really good
to my eyes
not to c6 knight f3 is hanging in many
variations too exactly perhaps you can
even sacrifice on e5 25 and go bishops i
think we're starting to figure out that
every move wins yeah right now we're
warming up to uh black's position very
very much so asian okay all right of the
many
very tempting alternatives uh bishop a6
well the key of the position is that you
want to maintain the knight on d4 yeah
if that knight stays on d4 then you're
good to go exactly and now alice just
played i like that give yourself a
chance right give yourself a chance in
this fight threaten f6 throw an fg make
your opponent find stuff i'm not really
sure what the idea is against rook g3
but
i think rook g3 is the is the clanker
that's the problem with f5 i i agree
with you you
open up the position for your bishop
your rook f4 f5 the only problem the
knight on the e5 rook g3 is to take
they check
take on e5 take on g6 or queen f4 first
yeah either queen f4 first or take on g6
and then queen f4 and try to
invade
there is a knight at three and the
biggest chance for alice to lead the
ruler down to 42 seconds and ray has
resigned ray was a rook down and he did
lose the game sorry uh to interrupt you
yeah let's go back to the game knight f3
played instead all right whoa whoa
knight knight takes just possible right
things are heating up knight takes f3
played
i like that move knight f3 by
simplifying the position yes do not get
checked maybe on the f file and she took
on f3 and i'm assuming we want to say or
something like that on a dark square
so i don't want to put my king on a
light square and i don't want to take
the pawn on f3 that's that's taboo yeah
so he has moved to h2 i expect something
to e2 i'm not sure
but guys after knight takes f3 did
stavroula have
e3 oh she may very well have
an opportunity for e3
uh right here
uh you know i wasn't even looking in
that direction right i mean i was just
thinking that this uh but i liked your
rook e2 especially too alejandro takes
on e1 on the board and
rook e3
again i still see right i don't i don't
feel like black is not in control
anymore because there's checks right
queen a1 for example
there's this dark square there's a lot
of dark spheres i feel like black space
and the benefit of this pawn on
f
and queen rookie is coming exactly
exactly that i i do think it's uh
black for choice
absolutely
jeffrey has drawn against javier connor
we'll go back and check out that game
but let's just i do want to go through
the dominguez game right now because
he's putting uh
a tight knot on
sam shanklin's position right now i see
just a second where is it it's right
there
oh that's a piece and that queen
oh sorry it's a pawn no it's not a piece
um
we just seen the move h4 queen c5 can
you see can i take on g i think you can
and then no you can take on d4 take on
d4 on d5
which he went and i think you just take
on g5 exactly oh
why did he do that he could have played
oh he must have forgotten about knight
g2 okay
bishop takes d5 doesn't work
d5 would be embarrassing and if you take
on g2 i think he takes g5 exactly you
take on g5 you're going to be a pawn up
but is that enough
but what about bishop to d bishop d3
knight e2 bishop to e2 rook takes g5
yeah i assume oh bishop back bishop to
b3
all right it could take on g5 still
right exactly f4
he goes 93 chuck
king up
this one is going to be an end game he
had much better chances before
i agree with that uh jeffrey already
what happened to uh tatev
they're they're in a long fight i would
say that's the last long fight long
fight yeah and then let's go to the
alice lee game i think we should go
think that's that one yeah
definitely taught it up because black's
king is suddenly
exposed how did that happen queen a1
shaq captured on g6 and the queen landed
on
d8 and it feels that pawn on f3 is
helping white so much and that's
stability wants to get rid of it
sacrifice
that diagonal please open up the
diagonal alice please take my rook on e2
no chance that happens uh no way that
you can allow that who's playing for a
win
i think it's ali right i think
28 probably is going to be met with rook
t8 right
the more i see this position the more i
think neither oh no but this queen b3
check says i want to win a pawn i want
to go after this pawn on
on
b4
and
like you say
using this pawn on f3 is a kind of a
shelter
queen e6
okay that's so a clever move
all right
well if you tried queens because the
idea is she wants to take on g4 no she
won and then take on f2 and land with
the checkmate so take a quick b4 you
have to be 44 exactly take on b4 then i
guess
she's ready to take on a2 and 11 seconds
or something
that is a big deal that is the big deal
rook takes e2 that surprises me but this
should just be a drawer you take on okay
because now all of those parts all those
bonds die whoa but so does the pawn on
b4 yeah it's a draw it's a bishop
b4 or a5 first
you better take that pawn on beat ooh
that was a shadoob
and tatev has won her game we'll go back
to that one
but okay this is a dead dead dead
draw yeah we can
won her game that's won her game and we
still have the game between linear and
this is just a draw guys so we can move
out of it
sam against linear let's take a look at
that again near slightly worse in this
drawn rook ending
um yeah why it works though
yeah and there is an admission
and by the way there was a
i think that's a three-fold repetition
claim
right
and that's it all right draw between
samsung and leonardo dominguez i think
samsung can be considered himself lucky
this is the last game remaining it is
still a
pretty dead draw
are they still actually playing this
game ah yes i'm wondering who has more
losing chances but i guess
neither one right well uh
alice just played the move bishop to e1
to keep making sure i mean white is the
only one that can lose this position if
you go through the if you try to take my
bishop and i think your mission is on
the other side
so
there she goes yeah but you can just
keep the king on d2 it's pretty pretty
easy you have enough room on g3 and e1
you know right
i mean the pawn on e2 is one square away
from coronation right
wow
what a roller coaster we've had in all
of these games
that's what player of chess does that's
amazing it's just amazing sometimes
players rise d5 really
i mean it's still a draw but which
direction are you going exactly f3 okay
king e6 is going to come on the board
yeah but
i understand what she's doing now i'm
starting to understand what she's doing
she wants to sacrifice the bishop
is that going to be enough is that going
to be winning for white so we go bishop
king f4
3 bishop to d3 oh that's fine you've got
to go a6
but i go queen queen
i queen the pawn
oh why do you queen you take my queen i
take you go a7 i go bishop to d5 yes but
then i still sacrifice though and it's
still a draw so that's right
is this a draw that's the that's the
point
i don't think so all right
right there's only one player who can
win and it's definitely not black this
is lost right oh you go g6 g7 i think
you just put the king on g7
okay but hold on the tempo is
it's not easy this is not easy yet
because
g6 oh she played g6
i think this was a very good move
because then it allows king king g5
that's very important and the part of
the h6 goes all the way yeah yeah no no
that's no no i'm not sure that wins king
g5
yeah h5 push the h-bone just push d-h i
think alice has this yeah let's have
this
don't go g7 don't go g7 don't go g7
king g5 h5 yes i think g7 also wins
i think g7 wins bishop c4 king g5
king g5 is key king g5 i think is
important
i think pg5 is the only win but she
found it yeah king g5 well but
h5 no bishop g8 h5 sorry bishop g8 king
g6
king e4
yeah that you got me with that king g6
move that was yeah
but that was crazy
truly well so much for calling this a
draw
our producers had it right
[Laughter]
tom's the man how dare you how dare you
ever have any doubts you two
i think she would have drawn that game
if she didn't have a need to pune
exactly right yeah you would keep yours
you just keep your kids
you'd never uh lose that that was insane
three decisive results okay three
players that are right now in a must-win
situation let's see how we got there
unless the producer wants to show us
something right now
oh
that's the result that we have resolved
right now and then we're going to go
through the moves and see what happened
in the other games
in our marquee matchup
ray robson was surprised from the
opening that he used earlier levon just
out prepped him out played him
outclassed him and one with the black
pieces very easily and now levon is in a
just needs a draw with the white pieces
great situation there for the number one
player in the country second up is
jeffrey shanghai as fabiano caruana uh
this game ended in a
in a move draw but it doesn't seem like
either player got the better of
the other surprising trump uh surprising
trump but it didn't yield jeffrey quite
enough to win the game um don't think
that he was worse either at all uh this
kind of dissipated into a draw and
meanwhile in the other matchup here
samsung clinton consider himself very
lucky to draw this game against lanier
dominguez certainly something wrong
happened from the opening lanier got a
really nice advantage there but
slowly but surely he started to slip
and he wasn't able to convert a winning
position meanwhile in the ladies we had
some drama uh statement
took advantage of a horrific blunder by
ana satonski in admittedly already a
very difficult position where tatev had
all the pressure in the position anna
just dropped an important part on her 5
with chuck and that cost her the game
tata wins 2 in a row now needs to draw
with the black pieces anna in a must-win
situation alice lee
proved the more resourceful player in a
completely dead drawn end game star
ruler went crazy there's no other way to
put it right a completely wrong plan to
try to capture that bishop and ends up
losing the game miscounts i'm not really
sure what to say about this one but
alice wins and now star ruler must
strike back with the white pieces what a
crazy turn of events
whoa
and we have some time to analyze i want
to go to the tatif game
i have it in front of me i'll i'll but i
was going to go to that one
i'll take you through all of them guys
yes tativ's game complete madness but
let's start with this one the game
between sam shanklin and dominguez
dominion has got the best position that
he can get in this type of structures
right he has control over the dark
squares he has the beautiful knight on
f6 attacking getting ready to snatch
that pawn off the board on d5 against
the bad bishop on b3 he has full control
of this position also this king has to
stay on f1 otherwise you're going to get
checkmated with rook to e1 so you have
to deal with a lot of threats and a lot
of problems as white he plays the move
h5 improving the position of course very
very good move fh3 in this position g5
sure let's try to um attack on this side
gain more space ask even more questions
from white
he plays the move rook to c3 knight
takes d5 finally i'm going to get that
pawn off the ball rook to c1 and now we
have knight to f4 it seems like
everything is coming along just nicely
rook to d1 queen to b5 check bishop to
c4 of course you cannot allow knight to
e2 so if you go king to d1 knight to e2
uh would finish the game
on the spot queen to b5 bishop to c4
queen to c6 i think this is where we
switched
to lanier's game we saw this mating
threat with queen to g2 he has to defend
sam shanklin that is with the move f3
and this was in my
opinion the critical moment because
black had the simple strategical option
of just killing any sort of counter play
from white with the move h4 right
cementing the knight on f4 you're never
going to be able to go g3 right now this
knight is going to live on f4 forever
you cannot take on d6 you don't have
time to do that because queen takes c4
yes my rook is hanging but you're in
check right so you cannot do that maybe
this is what he missed he played the
move queen to c5
which
of course it looks like it does the
right thing you're exchanging the queens
you are a pawn up you have a very
beautiful knight on f4 the problem is it
allows this very uh
foxy move by sam shanklin h4 very nice
move uh targeting the pawn on g5 the
only defender of the knight on f4 and we
know knights feel best when they have
outposts and after this h4 the knight on
f4 is losing the outpost queen takes d4
rook takes d4 d5
h takes g5 and the position is already
okay black still has a little bit of an
advantage nevertheless is not what it
used to be
and we ended up in a draw let's see what
happened in the game between abrahamian
and zatonski this one it felt like black
solved her issues out of the opening and
then we got all the way
to this position in oculus looking
position it does feel like white has a
little bit of an advantage potentially
with this pawn on e6 but what if i just
threaten to exchange the queens you're
going to be able to take take maybe take
on b7 but then i have to move rook to c4
and this should be just fine rook to c6
as well is an option force the pawn to
e7 then i'm going to get behind the pawn
i'm going to bring the king all the way
to f7 this should be an easy draw
instead of that
she plays queen to e2
she forgot about the pawn on f5 queen
takes f5 forces resignation on the spot
king to h8 was played actually king to
h8 was not even played queen to f5 that
was it the game was over in one move
and the other decisive result we just
saw the game between alice lee and so
lucky do three decisive results
and we're moving on to the round number
two
thank you for
the summation there christian i mean
for the game 10
there's a lot of content in these games
and i'm again i
for for me uh lavone's
victory uh as black was the most
impressive i mean it just it's team
rolled over wow
it was
really really really nicely done and uh
well talk about recovering from the
classical loss in the best way possible
as ray robson uh is now facing
elimination well ray robson started the
day needing a win with the white pieces
against levon neronian and now finds
himself needing a win against lebanon
but with the black people he didn't
think that the first challenge was
enough
he wanted to give himself a little bit
harder challenge there's a limp olympus
and there's everest and
here we go as the players get ready for
the second playoff game yeah we will be
starting momentarily the players are
already on their in their seats
this is going to be exciting i want to
see
the must wins right it's the ruling i
must win
anna isn't a must win and rey isn't a
must win
uh
a bit surprising by ana's choice of
defending yet again uh the the petrov
um not her usual repertoire and she
didn't no no
well is it yeah yeah it's pretty much
the only thing she plays
i thought french is also she played
french but i think she gave up this
quite a while ago she plays french and
bad traffic okay
okay
uh
neither of those games
she seemed at all comfortable but okay
here she is yeah d4 it worked in the
first game let's see if it works in the
second knight f3 e6
e3 going for the slower more strategical
game
e3 and now we're going to see d5 most
likely or c5 potentially from tatif
and then we have a lot of
interesting battles especially the one
in uh aronian versus robson as well
nice sorry it's just uh
trying to get the uh game
on my screen there
this is ray robson's and
lavonne uh has been trying to
master one e2 e4 yes yes he certainly
has and from ray's point of view uh
needing a win as a black uh an open
sicilian no he's not being gifted in
open sicilian and this c3 bishop e2
to be fair i don't mind if i absolutely
need to win a game playing this with
black you just get some kind of position
where it's not better exactly and just
play chess
right
in the dominguez channel game we all
have of course a heavy theoretical
battle this one in a night or extremely
sharp night or already right
and perhaps we can take a look at the
position there with this yes i've got
this happening
yeah very theoretical battle knight to
c5 i've seen these
uh ideas as well uh b4 and knight five
whoa
whoa is that the first move that comes
to mind e5
that's a visual allowing knight e6
allowing knight a6 allowing ed5
i'm thinking knight e6 and bishop a6
with the idea of bishop b5
and here we go 96 uh lanier
again
both of these players very very very
very well prepared wow what theoretical
geniuses but
d5 d5
well you can't argue with the engine
nowadays so
it is what it is
cool
and let's uh not forget right now sam
strangling with 10 minutes and 59
seconds they started off with 10 minutes
and gaining five seconds per move per
move getting up to 11. whatever okay
how did he do that i mean steph's prep
is amazing you got to give him that that
sounds really really sometimes you look
at some positions and it's like how did
this guy get there and remember it
exactly
because that's that's the other thing
too i mean how many variations do you
have to remember right like just to get
to a position where maybe you've got
something up here right now on your
portion we actually see the game between
lev and ray ruffs and and on the
analysis we have sam shankman's game
still oh i'm sorry i've got yeah i i was
i've been looking at the sam's shank
game i guess
i beg your pardon because it was this
amazing move by uh sam this move and the
way he keeps blitzing this out thinking
like the knight on d5 boom boom boom
clearly is still in his prep right what
a crazy position though i would if i
didn't see that sam blitzed out all of
these moves i would assume that black is
about fifteen hundred and then that's
definitely lost yes
like not even
right
like everything is wrong you know uh the
pawn on e6 the double pawns the pawns
bishops there's a hook on h6 so h4 g5 if
ever you you try to
castle but and
in the words of bobby fischer you know
you put the bishop on c4 because you
don't get made it
and i don't know uh you tell me what is
it about black's position that sam
enjoys is he is he is he playing for a
queen c7 knight e3 bishop c5
it's a little
perplexing this is a mystery to me yeah
and he played it very quickly which
means he knows it he knows he absolutely
must know this position
um and once again i'm looking at bishop
c4 but okay i play knight d2
logical coming to a good square e4 c4 b3
covering these very nice squares you
never know when king b1 is useful i
understand knight c3 is an issue
sometimes but it's not immediately
definitely not immediately because the
dark square bishop
on e3 can always drop back in any case
black
black needs to get his development uh in
in high gear
here whether it's with bishop d6 and
castles or bishop e7 in castles but
you've got to be
you've got to threaten knight takes g4
at some point and
fight for the initiative before white
just puts his
um grip the positional grip on the
position
yeah
again i think white's better but
but sam blessed everything so like black
white cannot be better right exactly
i'm just waiting for sam to come in and
say yeah at this point he knows that the
preparation is triple zeroes it's like
what
sorry christian what did you say no he
knows everything he does everything yeah
okay queen c7 uh sure knight takes e3
bishop c5 maybe that has his attention
um
i've
been expecting to move bishop c4 for
some time
lanier has not responded as quickly as
sam and i just want to quickly move
please the main game the one between
aronia and ray robson because ray robson
a difficult task winning with the white
pieces on demand against leveronia yeah
now this is a herculean task to win with
the black pieces on demand exactly
against leveronian exactly but he's much
better right now already is
he ray robson has a clear advantage
right now if he goes d5
d5 yeah the funny thing about d5 is that
sometimes you're better but you don't
want to play it because it's simple
you're you're afraid that everything is
traded off
after
and guess what he played it played it
boss boss
so what is going on here why bray wins
this game
i'm gonna go home thinking you know like
we don't know anything anything about
that he's giving himself a clear shot
at equalizing the match and taking it to
the armageddon but that's remarkable why
is it so
if we take i'm assuming you take it with
the knight yeah and it's coming out
great on g7 you'll take on g7 and then
the reference
then i'm going to move my rook and if
you put your knight on f4 put my bishop
on f1
i've kind of neutralized i agree my
queen
is not any great p1 is bad i'm going to
get the queen to f6 then i'm going to
get my rooks on the central fires d8 and
c8 it's going to be a slow grind in
which i have a stable long-lasting
advantage and you're going to be the one
that has to find a way to get your
pieces out get especially that queen
from b1 because you put it on c2 that's
going to be immediately attacked with an
item b4 most likely where do you put the
queen how do you get out you're probably
going to have to lose a lot of tempes
you're going to have to go a3 maybe then
queen to c2 in the meantime i'm going to
be able to get my pieces on the right
squares
it's it's serious the advantage right
now it's quite serious it's remarkable
because i didn't
think of it as being serious but i
understand your point that what that
black's flow is easy and white has
an issue his queen on b1 is not finding
a good square so takes on d5 knight
takes d5 takes on g7
takes on g7 rookie one knight f4 bishop
f1 queen f6
maybe
clearly black is better in that position
i was thinking of knight e4 i know
there's a knight h3 check that may be an
issue though well it's a big issue
could be guys we're probably going to
get there i mean let's wait and see
right now uh lever onion seems to be
taking his first thing of the game
actually he blitz
most of his moves up to this point he
had nine minutes and 45 seconds uh
before the move d5 came on the board
right now he's down to his last seven
minutes and 27 seconds ray robson with
six minutes on the clock still a
differential there on the clock but uh i
have to say i'm very impressed with what
ray is doing right now oh yeah very good
i'm just going to take a quick look uh
at uh alice's lee's game she looks like
she's doing very well
she's not an exchange
yeah but she's got that beautiful
pawn on d5 and a knight for it it seems
like alice doing well despite the
material
fabi
it's got the two bishops and space in
space so it's kind of about
doing very well yeah it looks very good
there for white sam shanklin oh this was
this
massively
crazy open
sicilian i think lanier is doing well uh
that's a crazy game and once again we'll
stay with the lavon game for just a
moment and lavon may be
picking up on what you've been
uh discussing their uh christian didn't
want to have anything to do with
inviting the knight to the f4 square
played bishop to b5
yeah gift me the pawn yes her you see
that pawn you want to take it right
let's go knight takes e4 maybe bishop
d takes c4 who knows the knight takes us
first yeah
and then
knight takes e4 queen takes e4
and you've got a tempo against my queen
but how severe is it not an easy tempo
because b7 is also hanging precisely
yeah
i don't quite see it
let's see what he comes up with
and there he does it he does play knight
takes e4 thanks for the knight actually
yes forcing the issue even more
so how do you start now do you take on
e4 and then take on g7 or do you think
yes
i'm thinking i'm taking on e4 you take
on e4 and i'm taking on g7 i like the
i like to induce the king to g7 because
i never know
when it might be useful to get in a
check
uh and he's going for it i think
let's see
it takes e4 takes an e4
it takes on g7 i am giving the
opportunity to ray to potentially take
on f3
take on
let's just take a look at this how how
crazy is this if i go bishop takes
takes on f three yes
takes on f eight and now we pause queen
g5
because that's the move you wanna play
but you could also take
no because i just before
rook to d1 maybe right
uh is it that
simple well i'm forcing you to take on
f8 and now i have time to take on c6
yeah
no more knight coming together then the
fight on g2 is just there okay uh
i mean this but he has to calculate it
he has to calculate it
uh it's crazy guys that rey is in a
situation you must win with the black
pieces to stay in the match
and he's got
a real real challenge real chances
ooh
and we've been looking at takes on f3
but he could of course um
after bishop oh pardon me
lavon has not captured on g7 he has not
and there are levels
on the clock right now
so levana is
probably thinking i just want to take on
g7 but maybe i have to take on e4 at
this moment he took on g7 he did okay
and this is the moment of truth
can
that other line that we did not look at
uh with queen g5 which was your first uh
move there and then queen takes b5 but
we can also start with bishop c6 that's
why right instead of taking on f8
just to eliminate oh yes and that might
be a problem yeah so we take
uh
and we take on f8 and now we just pause
for a moment
queen h5 i assume is a is is inviting
king to h1 can you try and look through
g1 not exactly this is not enough right
it's not enough but he's thinking about
queen h2
guys you're in a must-win situation
exactly what do you do right now exactly
do you take on f3 and create imbalances
in the position
you know that you're probably going to
get the queen to h3 then the rook is
going to be forced to g1 you don't know
how to assess that but you hope that
probably you have enough well the
problem i'm having is if i play king g7
queen takes e4 am i really going to win
that well but but you have queen f6 rook
eight i you still try right i think yes
i think you're good there but i think
that'd be yeah
he's taking on f3 he took on f3 i don't
think that's a good move
hold on but
once again uh alejandra if i take on on
g7 on g7 queen e4 queen f6 queen f6 i
can take on c6 yeah bishop takes c6 and
queen e5
just i i mean it's gross i'm just
playing for draw as white
maybe
yeah that's maybe he felt that he he had
to
uh
take his chances here but let's hold on
i am going to refresh my board i
apologize does he actually have a chance
there
he has to play
well he doesn't have to play anything
actually he has a ton of choices he has
even queen d7 is a move here
queen d7
and levon only needs to draw so as long
as he can hold on to the light squares
easier said than done because that move
queen d7 is
that's really
a foxy move
i
i don't play queen g5 g3 and queen h5
and give you the tempo that you need to
play king h1 after queen d7
what's my move
uh help me here guys what's my move
i could at least not die with bishop d6
right
wait queen to
that's
d7
good that's like what the engine comes
up with but just when i play a move like
queen d7 i'm thinking i'm winning got
you you maggot
the chest
no i'm talking about the chest i love
playing against the chess engines yeah
but they find those moves oh queen g5 he
did play the queen g5 no bishop d6 was
probably the right move exactly exactly
exactly and the chess engine would find
it and i would be
tormented
but
how do you no that you're never made
here yet
i mean i think i think objectively
white's better
after rook takes f8 you're correct yes
you are correct yeah yeah i mean europe
exchanged right right white is better
but also you guys were correct about the
variation
the alternative variation with queen to
f6 and that exchange on c6 and then
queen e5 that was just easy draw easy
easy easy draw yeah well then not so
easy
yeah yeah well
putting yourself in a position where you
have a must win with with black is
asking for a lot
we do have queen g4 on the board king h1
as expected the uh
right down to a minute but i think
that's the least of his problems right
now i just don't imagine creating
winning chances from here
uh there is just one idea that you do
have to avoid
after for example move like this
there is this very very well known
tricks that you don't want to fall for
queen h3 threatening mate on a g2 you
defend the mate then you play rook e5
and you say oh wow isn't that great i'm
going to take this
and oopsie daisy
uh grandmaster ken rogoff did this to me
once and that was painful
[Laughter]
harvard
economics professor now
ken was with the imf
but international monetary fund but uh
yeah queen g5 oops excuse me yeah queen
no
ah i hate this i've done something wrong
apologies
uh refresh and we're up to date with the
play
queen is on d3
well we know what uh ray wants ray wants
to go rookie five queen h3
but here's the problem we don't go after
the bishop from white's point of view if
white can trade off the rooks oh but he
wants to go rookie too
ray yeah but still with a chance i mean
the problem is not that
he doesn't have
counter play it's like how do you win
well
you you plant the rook on e2 as well
right now i can play rook c1 i i think
you started with that right oh you do
yeah okay so that after rookie five does
that work i can check you first on d8
right
check on d8 and then follow up with
yeah like i mean i can take on c8 can i
take on c8 first no take on c6 first
they're gonna say sex just
what
you can play with c6 and then after
queen h3 what am i queen z8
i have ah i have at least a perpetual
probably mate
yeah queen eight queen f6 if i want but
i think also ruchi won i definitely will
stop because your queen of six check is
good enough so rooksy one in fact does
threaten to take the bishop i saw this
old rookie five idea yeah the problem
for black is that the moment that one of
the rooks threatens to join the fray
on the back rank you can't really move
your rook off the background either
right
okay so where do i just
put the bishop
the bishop needs a
a a secure spot so let's assume i play
bishop
d7 yeah okay i protect ceo
i i stop queen d8 ideas i do intend to
play
queen h
oh wait a minute am i dropping f3 in
that case ah
oh no it feels like everything comes
with a problem everything has a drawback
yes yeah
but by the way um
lavon pausing
in this very key moment and it is a very
key moment
lavon to play where three participating
oh do you mean he'd spend three minutes
or he's got three minutes left both
three minutes three minutes efficient
commentary
um
yeah you don't want to fall behind to
fire the clock here
but ray's already done
two minutes
yeah that's
crazy okay so
i'm thinking that the problem ivan has
with the move rook e1 is that really
encourages ray to drop his rook on e2
and there's no way you're trading the
rooks because that of course opens up
this bishop it's a diagonal so the rook
would be on e2 and the queen is coming
to h3 sorry i think we have going to
have the first player advancing to the
championship from the playoffs uh tata
webber having is currently up a piece if
i can see that correctly against
satonski but we'll go back to that a
little bit later of course uh
winning the first game
uh needs only a draw but rooksy one
bishop b7 was quickly played
by
ray robson as he anticipated this rook
c1 and that of course is ana's game
with tatev bishop back to b7
again queen h3 rookie two
queen h3 rookie five ideas
for uh rey if he can get them in
so just don't play rook to c7
because after ruth of c7 queen h3 uh
rook g1 let's show that on yes i will do
this queen to g2 and that finishes the
game
very nice
you get it immortalized
not in a good way
what was really surprising to me is a
lot of these checkmating patterns
actually have names
to them and what is this one called
you know there's the arabian maze
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah legal's mate and all
the rest i don't know what's this made
with a rook
don't play rook c7 it says uh christian
and don't fall for that okay well check
me
i am threatening queen h3
that is a big
that's a massive threat and he said i
don't want to deal with rook f2 i don't
want to deal with anything i'll trade
the rooks
so kg1 on the board
and again the times of the players uh
one minute each basically wow
this is where nerves i mean it good play
is good play but sometimes you just need
great nerves and to remain calm
uh the pawn on eight on e2 is
sufficiently
uh stopped by this rook on e1 and again
i think i think it will be a very
interesting game if
if not for the fact that levon has draws
exactly we have draw outs here i just
excuse me but yeah alejandro you said
that you can always play f3 right what
if i go bishop f3 now but then i just go
rookie one and the thing is i just don't
know what black ever does but what does
white do but that doesn't matter that's
what he's saying that he just needs to
make a draw the problem i had that's
fine
bishop f3 is that i was going to go h3
you know so i go bishop f3 you go rookie
one now i go queen f5 i want to trade
the queens
and you think your king is going to get
all the way to d2 before ah no no i just
don't think you can get out in any way
ah
so
yeah about h3 that's okay
and now you're crazy move queen f5 why
not
well like wow
although i could play queen e3 i think i
would actually they're going to have
five look at the look giving themselves
a chance okay they're just one second by
the way
oh there's a couple of checks in the
position white could play queen d8
scheck and queen d4 check yeah it also
doesn't look like that that looks like a
draw
queen d8 shack
and followed by and i go queen f6 ah
then you go queen f6 correct sorry i
keep on covering by the way stabrula has
lost to alice lee so alice sleep moves
on to the next round great play there
from the youngster only 12 years of age
she'll be facing arena crash in the next
classical battle and sterile falls to
the elimination bracket and there you go
queen e3 doesn't want to see any of this
business also
on her match
yes very quickly came the move h5 now i
like what you were saying there
alejandro that you could just play rook
to e1 and rookie too yeah
get rid of that rid of the spawn right
yeah i mean that pawn is really sticking
in your craw and
that's it yeah i mean lavon said hey
let's get out of here
no way i'm not letting you take that
pawn on a2 i'm playing b3
queen d1 look we need one queen f3 and
f7 is hanging
and okay no you're just taking it
yeah the game is over exactly
such a dead draw in that position
and yet
no draw offers no other offers allowed
exactly
but yeah you're never winning this we
can probably switch out of this into the
favi game absolutely and uh let's do
that as we do expect
uh the number one seed to hold
that equal position i would rather go to
the dominions versus
shankling game because that one is wild
and it seems like dominguez might be
pulling connected past bonds against
this pass h-bomb yeah but you only need
to promote one pawn to win the game
isn't
black's king in some kind of no it's not
it's really a mating mat but
it looks good 22 seconds for uh
dominguez one minute and 39 seconds for
samshan it does kind of feel though that
it's double edged because rook h1 h2 i
mean i have threats this bishop
c6 except you don't get to play rook b
one check because the bishop on e4 i
don't know out of his b1 but i don't
care about that i'll just go king g7
no i'm saying you put your rook on h1
you put your pawn on h2 but you're never
threatening to get move your rook away
with a
discover check ah because it's always
covered that's what i meant sorry and
then if you go over king g7 you just go
rook h7 and it's solidified there and
look at him
knight v8 with a threat knight d7 check
kg7 rook h7 shack and knight f6 mate
well
[Music]
i love that move knight b8 by the way
played
very quickly and h2 the pawns on h2 but
you're not playing
that uh yeah you're not getting out of
it you're right you're not getting out
of this uh
knight b8 was a masterful move exactly
it's pretty great
truly truly what's going on because now
isn't it time to push him baby yeah but
knight age five's a threat
knight h5 each tribe's a threat right
because then i do move my rook oh but
what's going on
not h5 if c7 have
rooks you want wait a minute what about
bishop h4
also oh yeah also bishop h5 i wasn't
sure how to block this i thought the
knight then you go c7
d5
wait what no that's c7 wait what is
going on if rooks he won knight c5
finishes the game
exactly yes
h2 massive blunder he missed it
knight d5 was that i loved your knight
h5 and or bishop h4 ideas because then
you're trying to promote your
sam he played it so fast too 95 didn't
make sense
and he knows it missed his chance well
that's a big blunder his head is
probably in his hand right now
oh no not wondering why why would he
hurry with knight d5 he had one minute
on the clock wow
let me see that moment again
yeah
that is insane that was super
double-edged i think after knight h5
like anything or bishop yeah like that's
a three result
situation
one check but the king just moves it'll
hide easily you're not on time to play
h1 because aslanier knows he is queening
that pawn
h4 but guys you're gonna get defeated
right okay where's the mate where's the
mate but this is good force him to find
it ah okay queen 88 is over yeah
[Laughter]
good coaching good coaching rook h5
rook h5 right good yes good move good
coaching eight
queen f8 queen f5 rook h7 queen f7 very
good thank you grand master christian
curio guys
uh favi's game is over that was a draw
so they will be going into the
armageddon guys just a second because he
didn't do a seven
round there has to be a mate right
there's a mate
finally on the board on the board
what a water roller coaster meanwhile
we'll have at least one armageddon match
guys between fabiano and jeffrey and
this is the last game remaining uh ray
robson trying to win this position news
flash
not gonna happen
but yeah i mean you have to try i guess
right exactly
there are also no draw offers which kind
of
makes the game going into the armageddon
one game into the armageddon and that is
fabiano carrana
against young jeffrey shaw what was our
prediction we were predicting two i well
we're predicting linear against shanklin
and bobby and jeffrey going to
armageddon okay yeah i thought we had
two but no we're not doing so badly too
yeah i said zero
i said we we balanced out we bounced we
did balance out yeah fortunately
christian nobody's taking your
predictions seriously so you got nothing
to worry about
you're safe
i assume we asked we started armageddon
as soon as this is done right i think so
too
well
how are the colors going to be so the
colors you flip a coin okay you uh i
think the higher rated player
calls it in the air calls it in the air
okay so we should see that coin flip
yeah and the winner gets to choose color
okay now there's the question for you
guys what's your preference
always white white i've played
armageddon three times always with black
and i'm zero out of three
yeah you have to go for white i think i
like y2
queen takes c7 and i think
okay i think we understand that
you're not
you're not making progress i'm putting
my king on e3 and uh you're putting your
king on d5 and that's about
that's a the standoff that's the best we
can get
there we go
ah but i have to say i mean ray you
definitely uh oh man we're extraordinary
today no no winning against levon
ironian on demanding the white pieces
giving himself a fighting chance with
black wow no no i mean i understand that
ray is getting knocked down to the
elimination bracket but i think he can
be very proud of his performance today
no question about it in my mind too that
was really an outstanding achievement uh
and he put the pressure on lavon for
lavonne
this will uh rattle the cage a little
bit
give him some kind of warning that this
is not going to be a cake walk uh into
the finals aprilia to the u.s chess
championship we're live on well he's
there's a lot of big fish welcome to
america welcome to america yeah exactly
and uh i didn't see it uh but
uh
tatef yeah
with her back to the wall having lost
day one yeah won three in a row wow
pretty impressive okay
and we have the armageddon format let's
take a look remember it is five minutes
for white four minutes for black there
is a two second increment starting from
move 61 i thought it was 16 or whatever
and black wins if the game ends in a
draw okay how many pieces will be
illegally placed
on the board
this is going to be wild guys all right
wild i'm looking forward to it as well i
love the armageddon i think it's really
hard on the players i i mean they they
it's so unsatisfying they lose like six
months of their lives
for the spectators this is really a lot
of fun tell me again you've played three
armageddon games you always took the
black pieces i didn't take the black
pieces they were given to me
and it didn't work out no not so much
wow yeah okay
and our women's bracket is complete
let's take a look in the championship
bracket let's take a look it is crush
versus tohuyorowa the upper bracket in
the lower bracket we got alice lee
facing off against tatev abrahamian
that's gonna be a very interesting
battle for the youngster and meanwhile
in the elimination bracket we have four
very very very strong women let's take a
look at the pairings there
where the two players going to be
eliminated tomorrow tomorrow that's
right so these are the players fighting
for their lives
and we have riya yan playing against
academia meanwhile in a
battle of the second siege versus the
third seed
right there wow we got ana satonski
fighting against uh star roulette who
fell twice in the match against ellis
lee in the playoff gotcha meanwhile in
the open section we still have one game
remaining that's it to uh
pardon me one game remaining an
armageddon game between jeffrey shong
and uh fabiano caruana i knew what you
wanted to say
there we go and uh that will determine
who uh we have but we already have
linear dominguez passing over sam savion
oh sorry you're not making his passing
over santa shankland
and
uh levon aronian passing over ray robson
but this is the armageddon that we have
i do not know if we have confirmation
that these are the colors
right producer
haven't heard they're just guessing we
have not seen the coin flipping we have
not seen the coin phillips so this is
not official we know they're playing we
don't know what colors they have uh but
before we get into that we do have a
guest with us she has qualified uh under
the champions bracket alice lee with
christian carrillo thank you alejandro
yes we are indeed with the youngest
competitor in the event alice lee only
12 years of age but so much experience
already alice first of all
congratulations
that first game was back and forth it
felt like you had the advantage then
your opponent had a winning advantage
and after that everything was settled in
the time trouble situation how did you
feel about that game um well i was
basically just trying to play my moves
yeah i mean i felt that it was kind of
back and forth because um i feel like my
opening was kind of good but
after that i let her kind of um
uh let her work invade to like c3 and
that was kind of annoying uh and after
that i was able to like trade some
pieces i think we probably both made
some mistakes um but in the obstacle
bishop end game uh yeah i think um she
was she just had a bit lower time and
that was basically how i won
and in the second game you were playing
with black pieces a draw would have been
enough for you but you sacrificed an
exchange out of the opening did you
speak with your coach before that was
that the preparation how did you
approach that game oh um
i mean uh for some reason like i think i
was planning to play uh the like
uh what i played against her previously
which was like um e6 and then d64 um
that would transpose into the qga but
like i figured that it was um okay to
like kind of avoid her prep um
and because i yeah she probably prepared
against that also and uh so i played
something different um i don't think she
was expecting it and the exchange stack
line um can be very tactical but the
line she played i got kind of a solid
position i'm not sure how much i was
worth by or better by
you won against one of the most talented
players in the nation you're moving on
to the next round you're going to be
facing tatev abrahamian how does uh how
do you feel right now
well i'm still a bit in shock because
the first game was kind of crazy and the
second game was um also
not completely clear
but of course it's great to be finally
able to um vote after like two days and
four games to be able to advance
um i think it was based on like a bit of
luck but i'm also like management with
like time strategy that sort of stuff um
so yeah i think yeah it's great to be
i'm able to win the match
alice so much entertainment you gave us
and the fans as well congratulations and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you our
congratulations to alice very well done
young lady
impressive 2300 wow and proving herself
strong here in a match format against an
experienced player really outplaying her
in that playoff perhaps the first game
was a roller coaster for the second it
was very smooth sailing there yeah it
didn't take a take a deep look at it but
i just
admire the way she handles herself in
the interviews and her play very very
nice uh fabi yes versus jeffrey fabi
will be white yes tubby will be white we
had a coin flip i'm sure that somebody
has camera footage of it but
uh we didn't have to yeah when you need
wood
but finally we'll be white it was a
virtual world
virtual virtual corner yeah exactly they
got an app for how do you do those
yeah that's a good question probably
there's a nap yeah you can grab a phone
and you flip it
[Laughter]
okay in this matchup guys we have seen
four draws four draws the player has
been able to really uh
get uh the other if you will land a blow
i went very briefly through the game the
one that they just played and probably
had a crushing position oh absolutely
crushing position yeah he lets jeffrey
go i'm sure he's kicking himself forward
because he had a nice advantage from the
opening it grew and grew and grew
up to the point where he was
black had no moves wow uh the
player of uh fabi's caliber doesn't let
his opponent out of those situations but
what did he do he just made a couple
mistakes here and there jeffrey wiggled
himself out traded too many pieces and
uh jeffrey got a draw now we're going to
hackable see what uh fabi plays this
case because he played e4 and then
jeffrey responded with the petrov and
the classical yes and french in the
playoff okay so let's see if he starts
with e4 yet again
within a minute he had such a crosstalk
position last game that he must try to
go with e4 i feel yeah i feel it feels
like
jeffrey didn't solve his problems and i
don't think he's gonna
solve all of his opening problems in the
ten minutes between the game and the
armageddon and with four minutes
the petrov is such a difficult opening
to play because especially
right
we've got a lot of interested spectators
here hello
yeah
i played cars with him when he was a
toddler now he's a young man did you see
that
you see the hair on that guy
[Laughter]
and there we go
e4 and e6 repeat the french okay knight
c3 takes on e4 ultra solid but very
passive opening
oh
i think not the roux i think somebody
called it like the fort box or something
yes it's the fort knox variation so
knight d2 was played in the previous
game yeah yeah
you can take on it through with the
knight this is ultra passive for black
ultra ultra passive but solid very solid
you trade away your bad bishop and you
just say i have no weaknesses come get
me exactly and uh save king also very
important
now we've seen
wasn't this from their playoff this is
exactly what they said in their playoffs
so we'll see when they deviate although
i'm sure that fabi was pleased with the
position that he got no doubt
you got the space advantage you have the
pair of bishops but remember there is
no increment until they reach move 61
which is kind of far away
and here he goes 85 off to the races
b5 wow
whoa well
g6
this already feels i
have to say that uh guys they're still
following the first game they're still
following the first they're still
following the first game
but it feels like white is built up of
why these crushers are admittable attack
objectively white
crushing coach said tell him that this
one
is
was terrible what is he doing what is
jeffrey this looks awful right
first impressions are just aren't the
rooks coming yeah a rover yeah but the
second impression is worse
guys we have the same position that we
had in the first game and right now
jeffrey has burned through one minute
and 10 seconds of his time why would you
repeat this so rook g3 okay we see the
first deviation which is b4 but
not exactly an exciting move right that
kind of helpful isn't it
i mean i'd rather have my partner b7 at
them before
i think i'd rather have my bishop on
f6 than on b2 or c3 yeah this is a plus
three advantage
plus three plus no way i would really
guess that i would have said a plus one
this is a plus three according to yeah
wow that's kind of sick bishop g7 wait
what happens on bishop g5 here bishop g5
is
like out automatically all right
now we know that
advantage
bishop well bishop f4 also makes sense
just defend the pawn
sure but bishop g5 was just begging to
be played right a4 crazy
is he going to pull out ray robinson
take on a4
thank you for the pawn no but i'm
thinking rook
e1 to d1 right here right now
and then i play bishop g5 no he pulls a
ray robson b takes a4 thank you for the
past pawn good move knight c5 okay so
now is the time to play rook g3 or h3 or
g3 something like this right right and
just go for the king side attack you
have more space so you don't want to
trade pieces including these rooks i
think you just put the rook on the king
side somewhere
anything
must win game four five remember that it
is draw moves jeffrey on rook d6
in the heart of the
position does bishop e5 work no ooh
knight p7 ugly move
c5
c5 we can take it knight b7 and the
exact same setup was played in game one
as well
really
wow
i'm not so sure about what fabiano is i
think he's okay trading pieces in this
version because he has a passed pawn on
the a file he does but
i would have
probably
i mean i i do believe white has a much
superior ending don't get me wrong rook
d one queen rook d8 queen d8 queen
uh and this past pawn on the a file uh
could make noise but wow it could also
just be winning right yeah isn't it what
wasn't there just
a devastating kingside attack in there
somewhere i think that sometimes you
have too many options on how to win a
game and you choose one it might not be
the most convincing but
with the fodder and a4 i mean
yeah the pawn on a4 is just such a huge
um
factor and the fact that black is not
trading pieces it just
exemplifies how bad this position is
right by the way this is what it's like
three oh wait three knight takes uh no
a3
knight takes a4 queen takes b4 no no the
bishop on the face i apologize there is
a bishop on avatar you can't take it
upon i cannot take back with the queen
because then we exchange and the knight
on a4 is hanging right what do you think
with the bishop
doesn't work
he was defended so is it queen d1 and
just uh
a4 okay because he had a moment ago an
option of playing queen d2 or queen d1
and i wasn't sure which was better as it
turns out
it might really
so we can get in f4 and defend the e
pawn not with the passive bishop i'd
make progress here yeah that's that's
the question queen d4 what a move what
happens if i take on
queen d7 of course
and that's why jeffrey does hey jeffy
just seems to be so nonchalant
about well everything that's going on
well that's not a lot of progress there
for favi queen before queen d2 the king
is now on e8 it covers covers the
the business yes yes very nice
on d7 if anybody has improved their
position in the last three moves it was
black no question about it and maybe
knight a4 is
a real
idea now yeah and jeffrey's playing
although i'm i'm i'm really wondering
right why not just
sort of go like bishop f8 bishop b7 what
if i take on a4 we'll find out
we certainly will
excuse me is that a pawn and do you have
it well no he just recovered his pawn
yeah but do you have any advantage left
is the question exactly well he's trying
to mate him
i'm not sure how
what if i just take this bishop and then
go back
to c5 yeah well can i worm in with queen
f6 and that's the question right also
now that i see i don't think there's a
lot of options because bishop b7 is a
huge threat queen d6 following up and c6
would be hanging in the chest check and
everything hangs with
exactly i think you have to play it i
think you have to play bishop g5 queen
g5 move the knight back and close your
eyes
he's doing it
move the knight back or move the knight
forward forward boom into the position i
don't think it has a threat
queen f6 queen f6 just eyeballing a you
take on h there's no increment and
there's 45 seconds left for jeffrey oh
we're about to see pieces fly
pieces are about to fly
queen h a check and queen takes h7 takes
a lot of time and there will be a
counter play against
the king so 94 maybe 94.
he's worse
is he yes he's lost
he's losing this is just great for
uh but he has jeff when he's five
seconds two it's a cool move queen e1
he's gonna try to wait queen d3 he has
to flag him
he has to flag him he has to flag him
queen d3 is still good but he has a huge
time advantage and look at that oh
wait wait wait what a move by jeffrey
queen d6 that is nice oh he's winning
now completely winning wait why is he
winning he's forcing the trade of the
queens no no he's not first of all i
have a bishop d5 but even in that
endgame is it actually winning
ah you can take on d6 and then bishop to
e8 or bishop to b5 and then wait and
then go to b and then flagger
but i could also just move the queen
right like something like queen c two
twenty-four moves and right zero two and
twenty-four minutes after queen takes
guys this is move forty-four it's extra
points oh it's not only 16 moves and
look at fabi's clock you're not gonna
fight oh really
really eight but you have to speed up
you have to speed up as jeffrey and
jeffrey
is knight c3 knight a2
definitely this is the worst version
because even king c5 and you get knight
d6 defending f7 oh that's this is oh
what a turn around jeffrey's taking this
one and who has more time who has more
time on the clock it's jeffrey show he's
taking this one yes that is incredible
wow
he certainly is knight d6 you have to
make a five right hand f6 f6
oh
i'm not sure about that one oh he had
knight f7
and
definitely looking for his chance with
bishop g6 you have to play a move
knight f2 oh bishop g6
you have to play a move bishop f5 draw
perhaps not so easy
he has to make it though flagged he
flushed no way who flagged jeffrey
fletcher 16.
[Music]
one more one more and he didn't and he
would have got his increment and there's
fabby did you see that look of relief
papi went
wait but jeffrey's wondering
why didn't he get a two second increment
he made move 60.
but we hadn't we the thing is i was told
it was move 60 where the increment
starts 61. and then we saw a graphic
with the 61 with the 61. and i never
thought this would be an issue of course
not but
could it be that
naturally on move 61 he didn't get an
increment and maybe he felt he should
have been deserving no wait a minute
but why was he playing so fast so he
just played
his last move as black
was move 60.
king g2
he did not play he did not finalize
let's see
he doesn't get those two seconds right
king c3 is move 60 let's see if he makes
it before his time expires so knight f5
check the king that's right one second
that's why and then it's no no he has
the dates here no not even close not
even close
yeah yeah because king c3 was moved 60.
wow wow
wow
okay uh guess who just became a great
fan of this format
that was entertaining
in slow motion too
great stuff
wow wow i'm sure shawn
did you see abby's reaction to vappy was
like
move 60 move 60.
two seconds increments
if he gets to play king c3 knight d4
what was he playing so slowly i don't
understand that oh my gosh he was just
like so relaxed nonchalant moving the
pieces on the board
blast those moves on the board and break
that's that clock fabby was incredibly
lucky because right about here this is
perfect you have three seconds to make
three moves that's this this is an
absolute this should be doable this is
an absolute dream position at this
moment
for black jeffrey this is a lack of
experience you don't you don't move the
night it's too far from the clock
you know what i mean it's on the other
side you push the pawn yeah you got it
my what
what a finish to this match absolutely
crazy
and i just want to boldly point out the
obvious we were saying that at this
exact moment as we get fabby miked up as
black this is a dream position for
jeffrey king of three king d4 bishop e8
knight d6 fabby down on time bishop d7
and if jeffrey plays knight f5 is just
resigns it would have been a match over
again
uh
fabi nini needs to win with white
and uh that is crazy that's crazy well
the man of the hour right of the second
however you want to see it fabiano
caruana somehow
wiggles through but advances in the
champions bracket he is with christian
carrillo fabi
what a game well first of all fabiano
congratulations we are still
shell-shocked here in the studio how do
you feel after this armageddon
i can't say i'm really happy
i'm a little bit disgusted because uh
twice he played this opening
and it's uh i mean i get basically a
winning position out of the opening
and twice i ruined it um
and i'm just really
uh i mean you know you expect an
armageddon to be a bit of a mess but
the position i was get gifted out of the
opening
um
like it's it's really a shame to ruin
this
and i i was playing terribly
um the logical end would have been to
lose this game but
um yeah at some point we just started
blitzing i didn't know what move it was
um but it was my only chance to flag him
did he know what move it was because we
saw him uh looking at uh those monitors
after
the end of the game i don't know he
might have had a rough idea that it was
close
i had a feeling that it was close but
i didn't
it still hadn't felt like we had played
like a full end game to get to move 60.
so i
i figured that if he makes it it's gonna
be
by a move um
but yeah at some point it was just pure
well he also didn't play very
practically he allowed all this
confusion with bishop ea g6 and this was
the moment when he started to burn a few
seconds and i
got my chance to uh to flag him
uh but yeah overall i i'm not too happy
with it you said he gifted you a winning
position out of the opening in both
games today with black pieces did you
speak with him about that did you guys
have any time in between games in
between the rapid games and the
armageddon or did everything just happen
so fast well i think it's a bit
uh strange to discuss openings with your
opponent during a match
and after it i just didn't want to
bother him you know i understand that
um it's probably quite emotional
especially since he had it
he had it in the bag uh so i didn't
really want to uh
you know talk chess with him
uh
abby uh you you mentioned the fact that
yourself that you came out of the
opening with really really a nice
position
i'm looking at this position that you
had you played the move bishop f4 which
was a bit of a surprise for alejandro
and i we were really focused on bishop
g5 i'm sure it was your first in in
intention but you backed off why well
this was just some sort of decision
making i i like i i thought he'll stack
the exchange for sure after bishop g5
yeah
and
you know i thought my position should be
winning without allowing this where he
if he gets the dark squares and you can
imagine some compensation although i'm
sure he doesn't
you know get have the time to coordinate
to get c5 knight 694 everything he wants
but uh
but that's the reason i rejected it i
thought bishop f4 i'm getting h6 or d1
everything i see um
and then i i mean i blundered a4 later
on okay i think i was already misplaying
it
but at least i shouldn't give away my
free
pawn like this shouldn't be winning
right
yes
we
thought it was you know winning also
yeah but as you say i mean you just
gave it up at a certain moment uh it did
these playoffs they they play havoc with
your nerves how do you stay
calm
i don't i don't
heart beating but i guess with time you
manage to stress a bit better but yeah
these these are stressful
matches i did play a lot of armageddon
um
in uh well not only in norway but
um but more recently at the end of 2021
i played a tournament and i think i
played like six armageddon games
because there was matches which and all
my matches seemed to end in armageddon
so
and um then i tied with rapport for
first place by points and so there was
like a final armageddon to decide the
the winner of the tournament
uh so
at least like i decided that i just like
to take white because um
oh it's probably a personal thing but i
prefer it what alejandro was saying as
well that in the armageddon somehow it's
nicer to have white
congratulations as you move on i mean
but wow what a way of uh
stepping across the winning uh the
finishing line as you say you kind of
fall we fall on your nose forward just
flag him flag him flag him well thank
you favi congratulations on your match
victory at the end of the day exactly
you move on to the chances exactly what
it is yeah let's take a look at what
that happens we see this flag yet again
some hesitation
yasser from now on he's not pushing baby
baby
and this is the hesitation move right
here it was king c3 and not king d3 any
oh my god there it goes oh my god that's
that is such all right let's take a look
then at the brackets in the championship
section champions bracket aronian will
play dominguez and sevien will play
caruana this is going to be quite
exciting i particularly want to see the
aronian dominguez match they have played
before but i don't think it's a very
common matchup at the top despite the
fact that both of them are top 20
players exactly and in the elimination
bracket and the elimination bracket all
to play for we will be eliminating two
of these players tomorrow
uh roxanne will be facing against
shanklin and wesley so will be facing
against jeffrey chung remember these are
rapid games faster than the sorry slower
than the ones that we had today they're
not 15 plus and they're 25 plus 10 but
still they're pretty quick and uh the
loser of that match will be going home
well they can stay around but
they won't be part of the tournament
anymore in the ladies section it was
crushed that
very smoothly sailed through and she
will be facing against another player
that would simply cruise through uh
and in the other one two players in
playoffs proved way superior to their
opponents in the playoff section alice
lee uh convincingly beating stevo so
akira and tatev abrahamian also
convincingly beating anna satonski in
the playoffs they have two lives all of
them meanwhile in the elimination
bracket for the ladies two of them are
going home tomorrow katherine anderson
will be playing against riyang yan and
uh star roulette
will be playing as ana satonski also in
game 25 plus 10 that's what we have
tomorrow we have a bunch of chess
tomorrow eight game well a bunch of more
than that
the champions bracket all of those will
play their first classical game 90 plus
30 as usual but we will also have the
first round of matches of the
elimination bracket two rapid games of
game 25 plus 10 if tied playoffs this is
their last chance to remain in the
tournament that is tomorrow
somebody will be going home somebody
will be continuing with one life it's
gonna be exciting exciting exciting
christian final thoughts of today it was
a long day it was an exciting day i love
this format i almost don't care that it
was a five and a half hour day this felt
really good actually six and a half hour
date wow yeah they didn't feel like went
by fast yeah to be honest i'm still
shocked by
what just transpired but one word that
comes to mind is resilience resilience
of tatev abrahamian forex especially
resilience of ray robson he lost the tie
breaks but still he got there he had to
win on demand with the white pieces
against leveronian and he did it and of
course in the last match the resilience
of fabiano caruana despite the fact that
he blew and he knew that he blew to
completely winning positions out of the
opening to fight until the end and flag
him right to michael movie guys tomorrow
we're going to have double action we're
going to have the classical matches as
well as the first iteration of the rapid
mini matches is going to be an exciting
day for you guys
thank you christian i will just say
congratulations to tata the most
successful day of her career against an
opponent of ana satonski she won three
years all right
that's been one day
so congratulations join us tomorrow
thank you for sharing your day with us
same time same challenge see you then
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the saint
louis chess club is prohibited